[Musique]
les russes n'ont pas la capacité de
frapper les premiers et ils savent que
nous ne disposons encore pour quelques
semaines de la supériorité nucléaire
[Musique]
sans vous rien n'est possible en union
soviétique
ce serait un grand service à rendre la
grande bretagne
et au reste du monde tout cela est
fascinant je peine à croire que je suis
en train de déjeuner avec tes excuses
plus mais je suis représentant de
commerce c'est ça
[Musique]
vous êtes parfait vous êtes un civil
donc le kgb ne vous surveillera pas
à moscou dites vous que tout le monde
ait du kgb
dites vous qu'il peut y avoir des micros
partout
dès que vous mettez les pieds à moscou
vous avez une seule chose à vendre
jour l'idée que vous n'êtes qu'un banal
hommes d'affaires
[Musique]
je regrette que ce soit vous mais
gréville il faut que ce soit vous
je te demande d'arrêter d'aller à moscou
je te le demande pour notre couple
je vous offrir sur un plateau la
meilleure source de renseignements qu'on
est en urss au moment où deux
superpuissances front de la guerre à
tout
votre mission s'arrête là
il ne m'a donnerait pas à une mort
certaine je n'abandonne pas non plus
et si je me fais prendre ilm exécuterait
c'est ça
ça a été ajournée
l'hautil
[Musique]
nous devons évacuer l'immeuble
génial j'ai besoin de vous je reste ici
je parle pas un hourra gore de catégorie
5 qui arrive tu as l'air d'avoir oublié
il est déjà classés en 5
[Musique]
votre père ne veut pas partir madame je
peux pas le forcer tout ce que je vous
demande c'est d'y retourner avec moi et
de m'aider à l'évacuer de cet immeuble
auriez vous rendez vous montez
douce marc cherry hill sans eau
il fait partie d'une bande qui commet
les bras car je leur obole
essai de choper ces [ __ ] depuis un
mois
vous savez ce qu'ils veulent ce titre
j'ai ma petite idée oui
tant 4 millions de dollars il est ici
dans cet immeuble l'argent du crime si
on veut avoir une toute petite chance il
nous faut le plus d'armes possibles
aux fai étage par étage de ce carcan les
trous
et ensuite ils vont tous ou décembre
[Musique]
on est dans l'oeil du cyclone mais si
vous voulez faire vos preuves
ces mamans
pourquoi
[Musique]
j'étais fait exploser les classes et je
me porte bien
et n'oubliez pas on tirent pour tuer
c'est lent travail petit
non
à l'arrêt
[Musique]
c'est
le lot
non
article sabrina
[Musique]
ça
une grève des désagréments de paris
ce soir on a une entrevue spéciale d'une
heure au programme puisque je suis en
compagnie de tonnes après le petit génie
derrière l'un des plus grands succès de
la bande dessinée pour adultes le sla
schürmann cela showman si c'est toute ma
vie c'est une oeuvre inspirante je dois
être honnête avec vous et vos auditeurs
je n'ai pas trouvé ma faim encore
on part ensemble en voiture et ce sera
vraiment super amusant et très
instructif on va dormir dans des motels
ils sont ruraux et authentique
je croyais pas que ces endroits existait
encore est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose ici
qui ravive ton inspiration ce pourrait
bien être la scène d'un massacre en
effet
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on est au
milieu de nulle part il faut trouver une
solution
[Musique]
vous ne trouvez pas légitime
l'inquiétude que cette toxicité
culturels puissent pousser des
personnalité instable a basculé dans la
violence j'ai dessiné quoi des milliers
de meurtres il peut arriver que l'un
d'eux ressemble à un véritable meneur
shooteur ce pays cinglé merde faut qu'on
appelle la police pour leur dire quoi
fière d'être un tueur qui rôde et qui
recrée les meurtres de mes bd qui se
passe
tada dessinée ça
cet homme s'apprête à nous tuer
[Musique]
mais qui imagine tout ça
olive los angeles je veux que vous
ouvriez la portière et que vous mettiez
vos mains à l'extérieur du véhicule
maintenant
tommy un genou a dépucelé soir c'est ça
parce que leur nouveau s'appelle
hollande oui monsieur nicollin ne sèmera
tu montes ou pas
j'aimerais que tu écoute attentivement
et bien ce qui se passe ici dans cette
voiture de police et il ya ce qui se
passe en dehors de cette voiture après
cette nuit soit tu va réconcilier tout
ça
soit pas ce boulot va te manger tout cru
parce que quoi que tu fasses et où que
tu ailles ça peut être des emmerdes en
perspective
tu peux me croire mais si la guerre dans
les rues ici
ce sera nous touche contre 8
suit et tu fais exactement comme moi
et toi jouit mais quatre mois où je tire
je sais pas si je suis fait pour ça
j'ai quelque chose qu'il faut que tu
creuses ou moches comment il n'y a pas
plus moche ils ont des gosses
wave vous pouvez pas vous mettre en roue
libre comme ça fin de la formation pour
cette nuit
dis moi oui
massif a engagé dans la police pour ça
les gens dorment paisiblement dans leur
lit la nuit car des hommes coriace sont
prêts à commettre des violences en leur
nom
eh ben tu vois c'est incroyable comme tu
apprends vite
[Musique]
pour aller où
faire ce qu'on veut
mais toujours ensemble pour nous le plus
important c'est de rester solide et
solidaire pousser mamie ça va être le
plus bel et 18 août
[Musique]
jouer il a décroché les étoiles
on fera le tour du don
à
m
ce type à
[Musique]
mais à une condition
qu'est-ce que c'était personne ne
pouvait le savoir
est ce dont tu m'as sam char
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dites moi les enfants vous venez d'où
exactement où
[Musique]
on en est où les clients potentiels qui
pourraient me suivre j'ai arrangé un
rendez vous très prometteur quelle est
l'entreprise laconia qui dirige la
colère owen jasper crise d'hyper 28,6
fait quoi ça me dépasse je suis dit un
sac base sac à main un truc pour
respirer dorée plus précise et qu'elle
est trop beau je sais il veut priver
celle à konya et d'arrivée laissez moi
vous présenter notre directrice des
relations publiques en fait tu sous la
table j'ai fait tomber des documents à
qui tu rappelles l'ol celui qui voulait
que te laisse tomber sa carrière il va
il a beaucoup de succès gentille macro
johan irsa il a aussi craqué sûrement
engone jasper sort avec ton assistante
quoi de mieux pour moi que de tirer un
trait sur mon amour de jeunesse en
regardant tomber amoureux de quelqu'un
d'autre mon directeur financier va
arriver brême tu peux la queue y est
bien sûr ravi de vous rencontrer
habib moi aussi quelqu'un ressenti les
ont quittés en très grave comment on
fait on savoir quand tourner la page tu
t'adresses à la mauvaise personne c'est
pas toujours évident de tourner la page
de toute évidence il a toujours des
sentiments pour toi tu es là tu morfond
alors que tu devrait décider si oui ou
non ce gars est assez bien pour toi je
vais y arriver alors
oui ça va aller elle bouge bien son
corps on dirait qu'elle a fait ça toute
sa vie
dis-moi qui n'est pas trop tard
[Musique]
paillé
alors qu'on annonce comme on dit dans
les meilleurs délais volta
m
[Musique]
maman